- He won the Mr. Universe
contest when he was 20,
and the Mr. Olympia contest seven times.
He is worth hundreds
of millions of dollars.
He's been an athlete, actor, entrepreneur,
director, model, and politician.
He's Arnold Schwarzenegger and here
are his ten rules for success.
(swoosh)
- Here's the goal, and whatever it takes
to get there, I would do.
So, I was doing my daily work,
cleaning the guns, going
to the shooting range,
marching 20 miles a day and falling around
up hills with weapons,
running at five in the morning
with heavy combat boots
and all this stuff,
and then everyone just almost drops dead
at night, is totally exhausted.
I worked out three hours and got up early
in the morning again to do my sit-ups,
and the push-ups, and my chin-ups.
There was a clear conflict, a dilemma.
Because the lifting was not a traditional
sport for them, they didn't like the idea.
They didn't even have the equipment.
I had to go and figure
out every way possible
to do dips with chairs, or put a bar
across two chairs, and
do upside down rowing.
Everyone would say this
is the wrong direction
that I'm going, or I'm in a dream world,
I'm useless, whatever it
was, I'm going to break
through that, no matter what it takes.
I needed to reach that goal.
That vision that I had,
of being a world champion.
Think big.
Because then you're going to get big.
Then you're going to go
and achieve big things.
That is the most important thing.
We don't achieve big things by accident.
So, shoot for the top, shoot for the sky.
Shoot for the stars.
All of those liabilities
that they talked about
that are turning into assets.
When I did Conan the Barbarian
the director came to me and he said,
If we wouldn't have you, we would
have had to build one.
And on Terminator, the director said,
I couldn't imagine to have anyone play
Terminator that wouldn't have an accent
and that wouldn't have your body.
I cannot imagine the line "I'll be back."
with a normal American accent.
It worked so perfectly that
you have this German accent.
So all of those things that
they say are liabilities, became an asset.
As moment went on, I grew and grew
and went from one movie to the next,
started making more and more money
and then I ended up being
the highest paid actor
with 30 million dollars in Terminator 3.
(German dialogue)
- [Arnold] My father, he
said this is an embarrassment
to me and was dumping all over me.
The other thing is, you
have to work your butt off.
If you think that you're
going to go accomplish
something really special and be the best
in anything in the world,
and you think you can
do it without working,
you'll make a big mistake.
Because no matter what I did,
if it was in body building or in acting,
or in the political arena, it always took
a lot a lot of work.
You got to put out and you got
to make a lot of sacrifices.
If you're not willing to work hard,
forget about it - this is another rule
that is very important.
Use your power of potential
and make this nation
and this world a better place.
It worked for this
immigrant who came over here
to this country with $20 in the pocket,
and I know and I guarantee
it will work for you too.
I said that I wanted to get into acting,
people said "No, you have
an accent and you have
a body that is too big,
and your name no one
can pronounce, be realistic."
It's the 70s.
Today.
Dustin Hoffman, he's the big shot.
Al Pacino, little guy.
Woody Allen, sex symbol.
Even when I ran for Governor they said,
"Are you kidding me, he
can never win. Give it up."
But, I didn't pay any attention
because I said to myself,
"What did I do when they
said you can't go to Germany,
you can't compete in
the Junior Mr. Europe."
I did not listen to the no.
I went, and it worked out.
And I used that attitude,
as a blueprint for the rest of my life.
Don't be afraid to fail.
Because if you're afraid to fail,
then you're always holding yourself back,
because you're afraid if you
go all out you may fail.
Well, in weight lifting we learned
very quickly, the only way you could break
a record is if you're willing to fail.
That's when you put on more weight,
you try and sometimes maybe you don't,
you would not be able to lift it.
Which has happened to me many times.
But eventually when you train hard enough,
you will lift it.
So, don't be afraid to fail,
I mean, how far can you fall.
In Austria, kids were
conditioned to follow
our parents path, but, unlike other kids
around me, I was very determined
that I have to get out of there.
And then one day, I saw the cover
of a magazine of Reg Park.
And it says, "How Mr.
Universe Became Hercules".
I opened up this magazine
and I read through it,
and it was the whole plan, laid out.
I asked myself, Arnold,
what is it about you,
that is so different?
Why are you the only one
that sees it so clearly,
the score, going to America, winning the
Mr. Universe contest,
and getting into movies,
and making millions of
dollars, no one else
talks about this around here.
Is it real? Is it just a crazy fantasy?
But, wait a minute, Reg Park did it.
Then it's possible.
Arnold, focus. The key
thing is to be focused.
Visual a goal, and I
saw myself standing up
on a stage just like Reg Park
and it became more and more clear.
Arnold, You got to go.
That just shows you again so much
for it can't be done.
This is what I try to tell you,
anything and everything can be done
if you can visualize it and if you
believe in yourself.
It was the same thing again
when I ran for Governor,
you can imagine when I
went on the Tonight Show,
and I announced that I'm going to run for
Governor of the great state of California.
People came to be afterwards and said,
"You're crazy. You
don't announce something
like this on the Tonight Show.
You have an official Press Conference at
the state capital. Plus, you don't start
with governorship, you
start first with Mayor,
or with State Senator."
And I said, "I don't want to be Senator,
I don't want to be Mayor.
I want to be Governor,
don't you understand that?"
(laughter)
- Well, the rest is
history, I won in 2003,
and I won also in 2006.
Let me tell you, you're
going to find the naysayers
in every turn you make.
Don't listen, just visualize your goal,
know exactly where you want to go.
Trust yourself, get out
there and work like hell.
And break some of the rules
and never ever be afraid of failure.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because Daniel Grantham
asked me to, so if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile,
and you want to see a top ten list of,
leave their name in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do for you.
Now, Arnold liked to talk a lot about
how important it is to have a clear goal
that's set out and achieve for yourself,
so my question of the day for you today
is what is your clear goal?
What is a clear goal that you,
you're trying to work towards,
to build that life and that business
for yourself? Leave in the comments,
I'd love to hear from you.
And of course if you like this video
and you want to see more,
don't forget to subscribe
to the newsletter
and to the channel and I hope
to see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entrepreneurship
to kickstart your day,
thank you for watching
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)